most internet entrepreneurs when they
get into starting businesses they do
things that are either black hat or gray
hat and then they realize I gotta do
things legit because I don't want to go
to jail and I can make more money doing
things ethically and not breaking the
law like you just like make so much more
money being legit
how on Earth did you not learn that
lesson earlier
[Music]
all right today's pod is interesting we
just had Billy McFarlane and he's famous
for the fire festival thing which
basically was this like huge Coachella
type event that went viral four years
ago and he ended up committing a ton of
crimes that he admitted to and
was a charged and convicted of like 25
or 30 million dollars worth of fraud we
just had him on the Pod very confusing
pod Sean I think not confusing but but
like mixed emotions yeah yeah I mean
he's an interesting guy he's also uh
complicated like most people and uh you
know I don't know I think we I think it
was pretty interesting we talked about a
bunch of things we talked about kind of
his
origin story how he got to the fire
festival and almost like where it all
went wrong so where did he start making
you know mistakes and then eventually
committing crimes uh we talked about
life in prison and what that was like in
solitary confinement and things like
that we talked about what he's doing now
how he's trying to come back and me and
Sam are a little bit hard on his new
idea I would say well to the point of if
this was a normal if this was just a
normal person random person on the
street I would not have been as harsh
but I felt like I I don't know for
whatever reason I felt like I had the
license to be a little harsh on this one
um we talked about that yeah we talked
about other ideas about what he could do
or other opportun business opportunities
he sees uh pretty fascinating guy
very fascinating guy the thing that like
that sits bad with me is or it makes me
confuses he's very likable he's a very
likable person incredibly Charming very
charismatic and I want him to win but
he did a lot of really bad [__] and he
seems a little a little coached in the
sense that he's like right up front
we'll say uh what I did was terrible I
deserve no sympathy uh you know I was
wrong and I was an idiot right and he's
very quick to kind of own that which is
great you'd want somebody to own it but
it's also I think
that's somebody who who understands okay
this is the message I gotta stay on this
message and
um yeah I gotta make it really clear
where I stand on that
it's like when you have like a star
football player a star athlete in high
school and you see them like doing bad
[__] off the field and you're like dude
you have it all man you've got the
talent please don't blow this it it
hurts us all to see someone with so many
gifts do such bad [__] and that's a
little bit how I felt with this and uh
yeah I'm I say this in the end but I'm
eager to see how this story ends I'm
gonna be following it and I think it was
a good pod uh Ben our producer Ben
thought uh it went great he was
messaging US during it but I uh I think
people will like it yep all right enjoy
all right let's just get right into this
so it sounds like you have like staff
like you just asked someone to get you a
coffee so are you like are you back I
mean you're you're you're in the mix
again you're working
yeah broke as hell but uh taking
advantage of you know anybody I can get
to help me try to rebuild and start
making things right and do you have like
a crazy
restitution thing so we should explain
kind of what the so this is Billy Billy
created fire Festival most notably you
may have seen I don't know the
documentaries or whatever
you just got out of prison but one of
the things that's associated with it is
you have like
more than 20 million or something that
you have to pay back in restitution to
some combination of investors uh
creditors people like that how does that
work you do you have to give them like
every dollar or is it a certain
percentage like how does that work
because that's a deep deep hole yeah and
it's brutal I'm like I just can't think
about that big number because then you
know I'll sort of lose track about like
what's happening today and tomorrow so
how it works is that I have to pay a
percentage of all of my personal income
you know directly back to restitution
like after taxes they calculated on just
like gross income so totally pre-tax
income so make like a thousand dollars
this week I have a set percentage I have
to pay on that thousand dollars but what
is in addition to that yeah what's the
percent is it like crazy or is it like
five percent it's more than five I'm not
sure like where it's gonna end up it
varies based on income so I know what I
have to pay right now but I think it
gets readjusted every couple of months
and then in addition to that pirates
giving 10 of all of its Revenue back to
restitution as well so if pirate gets
100K sponsorship deal like it'll pay 10K
right away and then whatever I get as my
like salary or income I'll pay an
additional percentage on top of that so
I'm just trying to pay more than I have
to why are you doing this right now why
are you I mean like you know you're in a
different situation I I firmly believe
that I I listen to your pot the pods
that you've done I've watched the
documentary I've read a little bit like
you made a massive mistake so yeah I
think that you you you deserved to be
punished and so I don't feel sorry for
that for I don't feel sorry for you for
having to do that I think five years or
four years however much you serve that's
that's a lot so my my current stance is
like everyone deserves a second chance
and if you if you do the crime and you
have to do the time like you you there
should be a point where it's like all
right you screwed up you get it you can
try again I feel that but when I see you
doing this podcast push right now I'm
like
should we is he taking advantage of us
like why is this guy doing this right
now why is he what what is he gonna was
he trying to sell or or is this
therapeutic or are you just trying to
make a living which well you know what
what's your what's your motivation
between this recent push
yeah so like first of all totally
deserved what I got and sorry I think
there's like days where I felt like I
got too much time there's days where I
felt like I didn't get enough just like
based on everything else happening in
the world so
deserved it was coming and like
definitely not looking for sympathy I
think there's two things here one is
that by doing these podcasts I'm getting
great like inbound deal flow so if three
or four companies are listening to this
and they're like oh wait he actually
does know how to Market he can get us
attention and they'll come and hire me
like that's amazing that's my entire
purpose of like doing this small media
run right now I think it's like looking
at your Twitter comments a little bit
this morning before I came on the show a
lot of people and other hosts have
gotten the same feedback is like why the
hell would you give a con artist like
any time of day
um love your loved your response but I
think the response to all those people
is like what did I say
you said like maybe an interesting
conversation that will get us money
transparency I said I said uh an
interesting person or a cure an
interesting person that would have an
interesting conversation and it will get
us a lot of views uh I think that's cool
like other people haven't been able to
say that so I think that's great but I
think to them is that anybody who has
taken life to the extreme or too far has
learned like a lot of good and bad
lessons from that so like they can use
me right and if there's like one
entrepreneur here who's trying to raise
money and he or she thinks like [__]
this is a little harder than I thought
60 days ago and they're about to send
out that monthly investor update don't
[__] up your numbers like Don't Go Over
the Top to to raise that cash and like
if I can stop one person really cool but
on the other end of the spectrum if
there's somebody who's going about it
honestly and they're scared to kind of
take that leap like if I could Inspire
them to go and try to make their brand
pop off really cool as well so I think
there's lessons to be learned and people
could kind of use all of my mistakes to
help them wherever they are in their
entrepreneurial journey and you you are
kind of a hustler so you um
uh we'll kind of Go Fast through it but
you basically when you're in middle
school started creating projects I don't
even want to say company because like
you know I don't know how much of a
company it is when you're in middle
school but like you were building
products and uh launching them as
websites that's right is that right like
in Middle School
yeah just basically started doing super
basic HTML CSS in like fifth and sixth
grade and so this is what 20 21 22 years
ago and it was pretty much like the Wild
Wild West days of the internet and
started a couple of like web hosting
companies and basic social networks and
that was really my foray into the world
of Entrepreneurship and technology so
you you make those sites you end up
selling them or you sold at least one of
them uh for like what like uh a big way
and a small win what would you do when
you were kind of like you're probably
2006 and seventh grade yeah yeah these
are a couple thousands of dollars so
life-changing to you know okay just
wants to buy candy but and at this point
kind of irrelevant but I think like kind
of got me into the game
um started a little bit of a bigger
media site called 24 scene in high
school and sold that 2014 yes sell it to
a company called buddy TV out of Seattle
when I was 16. what did that do what was
24c it was a Content Network and I love
the TV show 20 for so was basically
clipping you know Snippets of the 24
show and this is before streaming so
it's hard 24.
yeah exactly so it's hard to get like
actual media of the shows this is all
based on like you know Fox like aired it
and then it really was very little media
afterwards so I was taking like the show
that aired and clipping it up and ended
up doing it for a half a dozen TV shows
and I had this business partner at the
time who was in his mid-30s in Michigan
but I never met and he like orchestrated
the sale and then he paid me out on
Western Union every two weeks for like
the remainder of my high school so that
was pretty crazy how much did you how
much you make doing that it was like
tens of thousands of dollars like but at
the time it was it was wild for me and
from there is you you went to school and
you you graduated but you never had a
real job did you
went to college
um basically started living off of my
2014 Capital under this little suitcase
under my bed for my freshman year of
college and for the first time I started
going out like going to nightclubs going
to dinners like exploring what every 18
year old I think man like wants to see
what's out there in the world and flew
all my cash in a couple of months so I'm
like [__] now I'm broke sitting in my
college in this like small town I can't
afford to like try to find a car to take
me to New York City anymore like what
can I do so got back to what I knew
which was basic programming and started
a social networking website called
spling during my freshman year of
college and that introduced me this
entire world of like venture capital and
Angel Investing and essentially dropped
out of school
halfway-ish through my freshman year to
work on spling and then I started this
whole like run of venture capital backed
startups my um my wife uh through
friends of friends somehow uh had some
run-ins with you at Penn like like
apparently like good running or you know
someone you must have dated someone who
were friends of someone and she and she
uh they would tell me stories about uh
they're like yeah we knew him and he
would always rent like these fat cars
and drive us all and pay for everything
to go to New York City from Philly uh
and like he we just thought like he just
had some business and no one knew what
it was no it wasn't anything
inappropriate but it was just like he
just like just we all do it's this guy
who must have had some money through
some internet companies and he uh he
treated on all of us on a regular basis
yes I went to went to Philly for a
company called dream Adventures which is
kind of like this accelerator incubator
program and it was dating a girl at the
time who was I think it's a sophomore
now at Penn so I should have been a
sophomore in school so all my like peers
and friends were in college and like so
I'd be like at dream it trying to raise
money by day and then like at the
terrible like college parties by night
and then obviously trying to take them
to New York
so what what triggered this switch from
like
uh I'm a kid programmer who likes to
make hobbyist websites like you know
scenes from my favorite TV show 24 to
like I'm trying to be the man because it
seems like at some point you all your
business ventures switched to like
things that were super cool right you
did the Black Card credit card thing uh
you did fire obviously which was like
you know the next Coachella so at some
point you switched from like
kind of hobbyist websites to how do I be
the cool guy you know the Big Man on
Campus type of thing what what triggered
that that switch for you
yeah I think that's a good question and
it was almost like I was living these
alternative lifes and not really fitting
in with either one I was a college kid
but trying to raise money from Venture
capitalists when you know at my little
school the majority of the students
haven't heard of the word like venture
capital in their life and then so I'd go
hang out with these Venture capitalists
who were Titans of industry or you know
successful Angel Investors and kind of
go back to the college realm so I was
always kind of interested in merging the
Two Worlds so when I'm hanging out with
the VCS the college kids all want access
to this and they would hire me to help
like Market or consult so it was kind of
hustling and trying to make side income
to to fund a lifestyle and trying to
kind of keep up with this new world that
my basic programming had been giving me
access to and then at what point so the
was like your first kind of it wasn't a
real win like you didn't exit but you
raised I think four or six million
dollars was that the the magnet is it
called magnesis yes so
um turn 19 graduated from the dream
Adventures moved spling to the second
ever we work labs uh down on Barrack
Street in New York and I was there we
were now around he's like 30-ish you
know hustling entrepreneurs all trying
to make it I'm a kid and went out to
dinner with just like a group of these
friends I was starting to meet in New
York who are a little bit older a little
bit more established and one of them
pulls out this black American Express
Centurion card and kind of slams it on
the table to show off and I'm like [__]
I have 40 in my Chase account like how
how can I do this so I went back to my
wework office went online to Alibaba
before Alibaba was really like a
mainstream thing uh particularly like in
New York in the US
bought these black metal cards and
bought a Credit Card Copier they kind of
came in the mail took my Chase blue
debit card copied it onto this black
card went to the pizza place across the
street from the wework guy was treating
me like I was royalty went back into the
office and just saw these cards to all
the entrepreneurs in the wework office
and then magnesis was born
and how big did that business get before
it uh before it went South
so my nieces did Total like 11 12-ish
million in Revenue over three years and
my biggest mistake was getting
distracted by fire in the fire festival
and I understand this is forwarding like
years in advance but
in the run-up to fire festival for the
four or five months I just started
trying to get money from anywhere and
everywhere and basically milked the
magnus's customer base as much as I
could and then when fire crashed Magnus
went down with it so I'm just not seeing
it through was such a [__] up but
magnesis was just it was just literally
like it's not a bank account it was just
literally the physical card as well as
some perks like you would get like
discounts to certain concerts I guess is
where fire kind of got inspiration from
yes discounts to certain clubs I guess
or like a discount for like a private
jet service so you just must have
negotiated the deals or probably even
white labels like some other company
that had found cool deals and knew for
300 you got the sick uh card like
literally physically just a card with
your same bank account you had access to
like a townhouse I forget what you
called it a townhouse uh and you got to
go to some parties and you got some
perks is that basically the model
exactly then what was really interesting
though was the members were bringing all
the perks and benefits so initially I
sold these cards and so now let's say we
sold a couple hundred cards I'm like wow
Our member base is super interesting
whether they're entrepreneurs they're
people all these different industries
that my friends don't really have access
to like let's get a space where they can
all come and connect
so I went and rented a series of Lofts
and townhouse that I couldn't afford
where basically members can come and
hang out anytime and then as magnesis
grew we just built an app where members
would come to us saying hey I work at
this brand whether it's like this plane
company this Fitness Studio this fashion
brand let's do something special for the
rest of the members and they would
basically pay us to advertise and give
access to cool [__] to the members and
the members of pay us an annual fee to
get access to these perks it was kind of
interesting we're making money from both
sides and then relying on the actual
member base to create the offering was
it profitable so
I was just so bad with financial
management that we raised you know a few
million bucks for magnesis but we never
had more than two months of runway in
the entire history of the company so I'd
raised around and like 80 of that round
was already spent in terms of like
Bill's owed to employees contractors
agencies whatever so it's like always a
kiss to death like okay raise a million
bucks but [__] I owe 800 Grand and now
we have two months to run my left I
think my biggest inability was to
communicate like that problem to
investors I just kept saying like things
are great you know you'll raise a
million bucks and we're off for the
races I couldn't just like really
explain how much we needed and why we
needed it and that caused us to have to
basically become profitable super early
on so
just started monetizing the user base
way more than I should have which I
think diminished the value of the brand
and for like the last year and a half
two years of magnesium it's like we
weren't profitable but we were paying
all of our bills just based on Revenue
we just like tried to monetize too
quickly and too fast to keep up with my
like crazy expenses but even magnesius
magnesis had issues like there's like
stories of like you know the the members
saying we thought we were buying tickets
to blank but turns out like we didn't
actually have them or maybe like
Hamilton tickets I think there's a story
around that like you even had issues
then what what uh
uh what what were the what were those
issues
so when fire Festival came and I started
going down this terrible Rabbit Hole I
needed money from everywhere and
anywhere and that included overselling
and trying to over promise things to
magnesis members to get that capital and
it just like took everything down and
like I was wrong and I was like lying
everywhere thinking I could make these
miracles happen and sometimes we did but
more often than not we we crashed and
burned at the end so it just like
totally just like lost track of
all the good that was happening and I
know you you feel bad and you probably
feel you know some shame and all these
negative things do you ever just laugh
at like wow what the hell like what did
I do where did this go how great how far
did this thing go it's like there's a
reason there's documentaries about it
it's literally like a movie is there any
part of you
that just sort of looks at this and says
I can't believe
how far I let this thing go and how far
it went
totally and like I was like looking and
trying to think through the SPF scenario
you know for the past couple of weeks
and I think at the end of the day like
he's obviously in a completely different
Stratosphere but it's really in his
position it's really hard to say no to
someone with 10 billion dollars right I
don't care like how smart or how wealthy
you are so much of our decision-making
process is based on social proof and
when you meet someone with that kind of
capital it immediately checks off all
these like subconscious boxes that
create this phenomenon on social proof
and I think that like to a much larger
scale that's what happened to him but it
also happened to me where I had
thousands of customers or thousands of
members and all these talent and artists
who are promoting the brand and I was in
a position where I was just like way too
young way too immature and people who
should have
helped me were almost scared to say no
and I kind of like relished and thrived
off of that and this led me down this
terrible terrible rabbit hole and when
they started saying no I was too like in
my own head where oh you know I pulled
pulled this off and proved you wrong
before I just like didn't know how to
press that red button to stop and that
was like one of my biggest issues I
think the reason you're interesting
because every entrepreneur we have a lot
of I mean people who like listen to this
Potter like entrepreneurial and everyone
like most internet entrepreneurs when
they get into starting businesses they
do things that are either black hat or
gray hat and then they realize
they realize like okay this is sick I
know how to make money like I'm
proficient at this skill set but like I
gotta do things legit because I'm gonna
make way more money if I and I do the
same thing I used to do these like I
mean I've done criminal [__] as well and
I'm like what the hell am I thinking I
should do things the right way because I
don't want to go to jail and I can make
more money doing things ethically and
not breaking the law like you just like
make so much more money being legit
how on Earth did you not learn that
lesson earlier I think just craziest
thing is I didn't know really what
failure was until I failed on such a
massive scale
um I think part of what let me go so far
is I obviously had as many losses if not
more than every other entrepreneur along
the journey but I was really good or I
guess really bad at blocking out that
noise and I was so focused on like this
end goal of Nothing Else Matters like
let me put my blinders on just like keep
running forward and
I just kept getting jaded to failures
until the failure became so big that I'm
I'm locked in solitary confinement and
what was the end goal like for for me
it's like I want to make a certain
amount of money so I could have a
certain house so I don't have to worry
anymore so I could spend my monthly
however much I want and then there's
there's I me and I mean all of us have
some ego thing of like I want to prove
to people that I'm Legit yeah
um what what was your but I like had a
certain money goal in mind I imagine
Sean's the same way he's like well I
want this lifestyle I want this what
what what's your motivating factor in
all this like and you say I want to have
a 100 million dollars a net worth by a
certain age or I want girls to have sex
with me which is like we all obviously
do like what's like the motivating
factor I want to fit in I think I I had
two big like insecurities and drives one
is those initial investors who backed me
when I was 18. I wanted to prove to them
that they were right and fire was seven
years later from that 70 years later
after that so one I want to prove they
were right I was too insecure to show
any kinks to my armor to them and two is
I wanted to be the guy that just like
took you to wild crazy experiences and
I'm like wow like this whole programming
thing is taking me into this world of
entertainment I'm hanging out with Like
Rappers and models and Comedians and my
friends don't believe me like I want to
be that guy who can take you from your
shitty college or from your like shitty
desk job to this private island where
the who's who of the world is flooding
in their guards and having a blast so it
was partly like proving myself to
investors and to partly prove myself to
friends that like I'm the guy that made
this life experience happen that you
just can't get anywhere else
and we should explain the origin so you
you go from magnesis I don't know what's
in between but at some point you create
this app called the fire app and the
fire app was meant to like let you book
a artist right so you could be like oh I
want uh you know whatever Timberland to
perform at a party I can send a booking
request and he can accept or reject and
there's no middlemen or minimum you know
Less middlemen in the middle and so you
know sort of create a Marketplace for
you know people to book these artists
that was the core idea and fire Festival
was a marketing stunt to promote the app
right but at some point the two kind of
almost flipped in importance and
firefestyle became
the the overarching thing fire Festival
starts uh from what I understand because
you meet a guy who's like yo I have this
little plane and I fly to these random
Caribbean islands and you used to go on
your weekends you know in this like four
person plane hang out come back and you
were like wow this is so dope people are
like wow that sounds so dope you're like
yeah you should come do this too and
somehow your experience of like flying
to these remote islands and having a
having a good time became what if we fly
3 000 people down to this island and we
do this like Festival this
coachella-like Festival did I get that
right so far
I think you told the story better than
me okay perfect
but but somewhere along the way you get
something where I'm fast forwarding this
because I think you know it's documented
in other places but I do want to explain
it for somebody who's listening so
somewhere along the way you're like all
right we're doing this we're doing fire
festival and
you start promoting this thing and your
method of promoting was what what was
the marketing game plan to promote fire
Festival
so like it all kind of stems down too I
was for all my terrible flaws I was
really good at
taking a tangible asset that most people
didn't have and using that to launch a
business so magnesis had this physical
card that would cost me like two dollars
to make per card and then a crazy
townhouse so my entire Target
demographic didn't have access to a
black card they didn't have access to a
multi-million dollar townhouse in
downtown Manhattan when they're 23 years
old so I took these two like
inaccessible things gave it to my
customers and used that to launch a
business on top of fast forward to fire
now I'm trying to cater to these you
know b list rappers and comedians who
need small bookings these people aren't
Jay-Z they aren't Drake they don't have
their own private island so here's where
I come in okay now guys we have our own
private island
you want to be involved with me and then
I use that to hopefully build the fire
booking app so all my marketing strategy
came down to taking a tangible good or
service that wasn't available to a
certain audience giving it to them
making them feel like it's theirs and
they own it and using that to build a
business so that was the entire logic
behind like the fire app and fire
Festival component and as you perfectly
said the importance quickly flipped as
we launched the marketing for fire
festival and fire Festival became it and
fire app became you know a second
thought for that period of time it's not
like a bad plan it's not a bad idea I
guess like you said like on the Pod I
think when the documentaries came out we
were like honestly it was a dope idea
and somebody like if it had just been
done like and it wasn't even like it's
not like theranos where you're like that
was a dope idea if somebody had just
done it right it's like well maybe it's
technically impossible your [__] your
thing was possible you just had shitty
like Logistics and operations and poor
planning you just threw up you just
threw like the the idea of the event and
then the actual the actual event did not
live up to to the hype but your thing
was totally possible
um what what went wrong there why why
were you not able to to pull off what
you had sold the dream that you had sold
were you Bella Hadid and you had [__]
I don't know Kendall Jenner and all the
all these people promoting that hey
we're going to this thing it's gonna be
you know whatever the party of the
century
you sold the tickets so you got that
part right it's just you didn't deliver
the party
do what the craziest thing is I think
lying and unable to show weaknesses made
the festival fail and I truly believe
that my backers at the time were well
connected and smart enough where it came
to them and said hey look guys we did
this great marketing campaign but I have
no idea what the [__] I'm doing they
would have found like the best Festival
people in the world to come and actually
execute this but I was so scared to show
that I couldn't handle it that I kept
saying everything is great and
everything is perfect and that pushed
away the people that would have helped
me it's like literally lying I think
doomed the festival from day one post
announcement who are the big Packers was
it VCS or or family offices or what uh
handful of venture funds and then you
know
25 individuals everywhere from like
larger family offices down to just
smaller Angels who is the biggest fund
or most well-known fund
uh I just don't want to throw anybody
under the bus so yeah oh okay I thought
I wasn't sure if it was public uh I I
think that some of the investor list was
a good portion of the investor list I
believe was sealed in the court files
and I didn't ask for it to be sealed I
think other people did so I just don't
want to yeah sure don't want to do that
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
and so you uh you're like okay I I could
have asked for help from uh or
organizing people and this is where I
think things get a little tricky so you
brought up SPF
um yeah
I've I brought up theranos we're talking
about fire Festival I think there's
always a question of like was this
intentionally supposed to be a fraud
like oh I'm just gonna trick people and
run away and uh you know like with FTX
right now that's a question like
did something happen that you weren't
really paying attention to and then
things got out of hand or from the
beginning oh you were like I'm just
gonna trick people and take their money
um
for you where did it's where did it
start it like was it well intentioned at
the beginning and where did it turn at
what point did you realize oh I'm
I'm I gotta just say this because I
gotta get to the next dollar I gotta get
to the next the next milestone
so truly try to execute the event and
literally up until people were arriving
to the festival I thought it was gonna
work and obviously that's so stupid
looking back yeah you knew you had like
[__] you know tents and like grilled
cheese sandwiches for for people who
ordered Villas like what how could you
how could you still believe that right
up till the event are you sober this
entire time by the way
uh maybe the drugs but was like drinking
a lot but no drugs drinking way too much
never like I've smoked weed maybe six
times in my life but I think it's like a
common you know people are saying I was
on Coke or whatever never tried Coke on
my life so they could have a heart okay
so yeah back to so you're you're in a
sober-ish mindset and yeah you actually
think it's gonna work the day of
or the day before and I'm like Here's my
thought process the island is so
beautiful we have this like a local team
who you couldn't script these characters
they have the boats they have the jet
skis they're gonna take people out like
we know how to do these experiences if
you have some crazy Pilots like it's
just gonna be like a wild weekend that
you've never had before and we have 30
artists who are paid so you're gonna
have like A-list Talent one of the most
beautiful places in my opinion like in
the Atlantic Ocean and amazing group of
these like movie scripted local
characters who have toys for you to play
on so I thought that like okay they'll
go back and they'll have a shitty we
don't have food and shelter and
bathrooms but we got nature yeah
yeah yeah who needs food when you have
tubing but actually like I think the
craziest thing is if we Market it like
that it would have been amazing it would
have been better okay guys I can't
figure out the logistics I can't afford
to to build like 500 houses but
I somehow came up with the 5 million
bucks for the artists we have these
great people we have this great Island
like bring a sleeping bag and figure
this [__] out I think of that mindset
shift was marketed people would have
been way more excited and they would
have been like felt like they're owning
the adventure and it would have been
almost like yeah however many men years
were and like the marketing like killed
me at the end like the marketing sold
tickets but it also made it fail what
would the ideal outcome had been let's
say that like it just so happened to
work how much revenue and profit would
it have made and like what would the
ideal situation had had been
so I have no idea like my entire are you
[__] kidding me how do you not know
this so like I we had a budget for 10
million dollars for the festival I
didn't have 10 million dollars but like
okay I can reasonably raise 10 million
dollars just off of this brand we're
building right now for the festival
um ended up spending way more than that
and it got to the point where I would go
to sleep with no money in the bank wake
up and know that like that day I had to
raise a certain dollar amount just to
survive and some days it was 50 Grand
some days it was four million dollars so
I'd wake up at you know 9 A.M and know
that I have until 2 pm to get X dollars
in the bank to then rewire it out before
the before the day ended so my life is
[__] hell and I just couldn't like
zoom out so I was stuck okay today's two
million dollars I can call this guy I
can call this guy and like at the end of
the day things keep getting bigger the
brand is going to be so big if this
Festival works everybody's gonna get
paid and I just didn't like know how to
really run the numbers at that point so
how much did you end up spending
we've raised 26 or 27
um
but we were making money from other
sources like we were selling tickets on
top of that we were getting sponsors
magnesis was making money I was doing
consulting jobs so it's like literally
like
every day which is a different angle for
money so you said maybe like 30 billion
plus
I would say in this six-month period it
was probably closer to 40.
and the tickets so you sold 7 000
tickets is that right I think it was
probably just under six thousand it was
just like around three thousand people
per weekend some were given away for
free and some were sold so we sold a
little under six thousand let's call it
five percent Revenue five thousand times
what what's the average ticket what were
you selling these for so the average the
the the median ticket price was like 12
to 1500 however we sold like a handful
of outlier tickets for like a couple
hundred thousand dollars plus per ticket
so so then it was in five thousand times
two thousand you're uh what's that ten
million you got 10 million yeah in sales
uh and then did you have another couple
million from sponsors or anything like
that yeah and like the issue is that
some of the ticket money was held in
escrow some of it was for like these
yachts and boats so it wasn't like pure
10 million dollars of free cash flow it
was like everything was held up or not
held up in certain ways I think like my
stripe account got Frozen with like 700
Grand in the day the festival got
canceled so it's like you know money was
held in a bunch of different sources and
areas so the the event itself didn't
make any sense right it was like we're
gonna make 10 million we're gonna spend
40 but
you could have gotten so much more
Profit just by running a 10 million or
40 million dollars of Facebook ads you
know what I mean like this is just like
a a better or a slightly different
version of Cameo or something like that
like these marketplaces are tried and
true uh an event would have been cool if
it were like a break even or a slight
loss but that yeah but but put it this
way like as for as wrong as things are
and I can't do this tomorrow but if I
did fire Festival again in three years I
think almost all the first group as well
as the rest of like pop culture would
buy tickets just to be there to see how
bad it is right like
the brand the brand value is there just
like how can I do it appropriately are
you tempted to pick the right time to go
I mean I have to do it again I just
can't do it while I'm on probation I
can't do it this year or next year but
you know it has to be done again and I
think no matter what success or failures
I find along the way in Tech like until
I execute fire
have you seen his new company pirate go
to the website
dude trust me go to it it's
p-y-r-t.com Billy like this is the same
[__] that you're doing a little bit like
it's it's not like you said you could
program like like when I see what you're
doing and I you had you did the Met Gala
thing where you got in trouble for
scamming people out of that I'm like hey
just do a [__] course dude just
create
of course and make two million like me
and Sean make seven figures a year from
this stupid stuff it's not stupid it
provides value but I mean it's like
insignificant compared to an event or
like you said you liked the program and
you like content sites like just do
something like boring and straight why
are you doing this pirate thing it's
like the same [__] there's so many
things that's gonna go that could
potentially go wrong it's just the the
stakes are so much higher than just
creating some boring ass software
I hear you
um I think pirate is actually is that
what you're suggestions
no uh Billy we have uh 3 000 people
coming tomorrow I hear you
no you might very well be right and I
think the thing that we're getting back
to with pirate is like
I'm not trying to host a thousand people
on an island it's not gonna work I want
to get back to those trips on the small
planes with a dozen people or two dozen
people that did work well for a couple
of years and it has to be like a tour
guide for a few years of my life and
like eat [__] like I'm gonna go do that
but I can give a couple of dozen people
this amazing adventurous experience and
then while I'm doing that I'd like to
find interesting ways to broadcast those
experiences to all their followers and
then give their followers a way to get
involved so I'm not trying to figure out
the logistics to host thousands of
people I know I can host two dozen
people and if I can take five years to
build like really interesting like
virtual reality esque Tech that allows
anybody to like watch and actually
influence what's happening I think
that's like a really cool win and way to
kind of get back to what I'm good at
this is a horrible idea
yeah dude it
I I actually don't think it's a horrible
idea if it like I think you potentially
are you're you're
um you rank so high in capability and so
high in in ignorance like and that's
like a perfect combination I think of
starting a business which is like this
like confidence of like I think I can
pull this off and I'm capable of some
things that's actually a beautiful
combination but you also have this third
part of the of the pie chart where it's
just like reputation and like past and
owing money I just don't understand why
you're doing this it just you can you
you are brilliant at a lot of things
that just seems like such a startup just
a boring ass agency that makes 20
million a year and 10 million in profit
yeah if you just did like an event like
a stunt marketing agency or uh or
something so we have that we're
announcing it today actually it's called
the pirate Collective and that's how
we're fun that's what we're trying to
fund I guess our attack is so let's walk
through this okay so I'm on the podcast
I'm on the pirate website and it says
there's a picture of a private island so
we're already getting flashbacks of fire
and then it says join the crew a pirate
is somebody who turns The Impossible
into Adventure he says give me your
phone number and then it says join the
treasure hunt virtual reality so what
you're saying from what what I just
gathered of what you just described is
that you're gonna take
you know six to 15 people at a time on
those like little planes to the islands
like you used to do where it's not such
a heavy logistical lift
um yeah those people are gonna have a
great time they'll pay
five grand or 10 grand or something I'm
just guessing here they'll pay a lot of
money to have this really cool
adventurous experience and then you're
going to use you know video plus maybe
virtual reality to broadcast that
experience to other people who can't
afford to go and or maybe their friends
and their social media
um yeah and they get to maybe buy a
virtual ticket to kind of attend the
party that way and you're gonna do that
a bunch of times did I describe it right
or did I I'm just guessing based on what
you said what you said absolutely so the
last thing that you're missing is that
the people who are basically so
essentially we're going to partner with
this little hotel they'll handle all the
hospitality and Logistics we'll host
artists there on a regular basis we'll
rig the hotel with these 360 cameras
live stream everything that's happening
then give the people who are watching
the live stream the ability to buy in
and affect what's happening on the
island so they could like have one of
the artists go to the recording studio
and impact the creative process when
they're making their song or they can
buy the talent like a drink you know and
make them take a tequila shot because
you should just have you gone for being
Mr Beast like we hung out with Mr Beast
and yeah you're wired just like that nut
and uh and I feel like if you just
channeled your energy towards how do I
do the craziest thing that's gonna make
the craziest video that 20 million
people are gonna watch and then
continually one up yourself uh I feel
like that would work that's my
suggestion to you know and you
absolutely have the you have the
Charisma and you have the storytelling
ability just dude just do just just make
you and like a small team
doing the crazy [__] and do ad dollars
but it sounds like you're sharing you
want to share your screen you could
share your screen I I heard you click it
around I bet you sure
I'm not supposed to share this but okay
but uh I want to get back to what you
just said I like that attitude I like
that so
um this was an island we were working
with unfortunately I'm not allowed to go
to the Bahamas so this is just pure like
demo purpose but the idea is to take
like a one-to-one virtual representation
of a property
track where all the talent is in real
time track where all the toys are in
real time and then people can click into
various live streams once they're
watching a live stream hopefully
watching their favorite Talent they
could actually choose these actions to
affect what's really happening there so
it could be as crazy as me swimming in
the reef and the users deciding to Chum
the water and given the sharks in the
area I think a lot of people want to see
see that happen or as simple as buying
somebody a drink but and what what would
the financials of this be like I mean
I'm sure you've now thought about that
more you're like what would the p l what
would what does this
no it surely has it's like one day one
day it could do this what's that one day
so a million people paying 20 cents to
ask a talent to do something or to
contribute an action towards like the
real world so if everybody pays 20 cents
to Chum the water and a million people
are chumming the water then that's kind
of where the financials come in sorry I
can't do that just tell me like in in
five years are you in your head you're
like I think we could do like a hundred
million dollars in eight years like what
what's the you're not getting me
arrested Sam I don't want to promise any
Revenue but no no sorry don't promise
I'm just saying like when you're laying
in bed you're like I think this could
become like a 100 million dollar Company
by doing this I think what's the way I
think about this and my logic could be
wrong is that once again I we're not
going to be using the Bahamas but for
example the Bahamas gets around four-ish
million tourists a year and if we're
doing these really interesting
broadcasts we can have more than four
four million people in a single day like
virtually come to the island so if we
can just like totally destroy their
tourism numbers in a virtual scale I
think it's a big Revenue opportunity
so okay so where did you come up with
this idea were you in prison or was it
once you got out that you were like all
right I'm gonna start my brainstorm
no I was in solitary confinement and
it's like totally totally confined and
you know a lot of it was just like
reflection and then a lot of it too is I
want to get outside of these walls and
just like
get back to Adventure and then find a
way to share this so we should say by
the way that's kind of where you got
into solitary because you attempted to
do a podcast from inside prison yeah uh
terribly what well first did you know
that was not allowed was that I didn't
even realize that would be such a faux
pas like that that was that would be
such a course that would be a faux pas I
think the biggest thing is great dude
they read your mail and [__] you can't
like and like each [__] each inmate you
have like different roles for you right
like if a journalist calls you and you
do an interview is that allowed that's
allowed
um
I was wrong the toughest part though is
like it was a gray area I think if it
was a clear violation of the rules My
Punishment would have been like less
strict I used the pay phone like their
available pay phones
um but at the same time like you can't
cause attention to the jail right and
that's what I did so I understand like
why it was like so incredibly stupid but
I think if I had a clear violation of
the rules I would have gone to solitary
for like 45 days and not seven months
you basically had a podcast host call
you on the pay phone and then you did
your side of the podcast from the pay
phone in like 10 minute or 15 minute
increments right because that's what you
were allowed exactly exactly okay yeah I
mean I understand why you think that's
great it's like what's the difference
between prostitution and pornography you
know it's like I don't know if there's a
camera there it's like you're you're
safe like you know I mean like you're
like playing this like uh like I don't
know if I would be if I would be risking
things at that moment I mean I I've done
I've when I was in college I did stupid
stuff and I got in trouble and I
remember getting in trouble and thinking
like I don't ever want to come back to
jail again and more so solitary
confinement seems like I would kill
myself I think I would want to commit
suicide like that sounds like that's
like the seven months in a box it seems
like the worst that's the worst possible
outcome let alone like you know getting
life you know like El Chapo and some of
these guys in in these like Florence and
all these like high high level security
what was that like seven months being in
that
cell I get anxious just thinking about
it
I actually think that it's
counterproductive in terms of Reform if
that kind of makes sense and
the other time in jail like I don't
think it's going to have a long lost
long-lasting negative impacts in my life
I did 10 months total in solitary one
time for three one time for seven I
think like that actually makes it more
likely that I make a mistake in the
future and obviously if I do make a
mistake it's totally on me but like the
mental
hangover that I have where it's like
somebody out there could snap their
fingers and put me into a concrete box
like that's scary like that's what gives
me the nightmares at night and I think
that like if anything that makes you
know ideas bigger or different because
you're kind of fearful of that outcome
so I don't know it's [__] hard and
like there are guys who have done way
more than 10 months and I can't imagine
what they feel like but I think that's
like the worst part of the experience
and actually it's just counterproductive
did you know it was going to be seven
months or is it like do you know there's
an end point or you didn't know
no and I think if they said hey this is
seven months then you're getting out and
then you're going home the year after
that it would have been totally
different but the fact that they kept
[__] with me basically saying hey
you're never getting out of here you're
gonna get in trouble more like that was
the biggest mind [__] you just like wake
up every morning and be like this is
never gonna end why like you mean the
the guards were just [__]
yeah in the jail they literally in
response to the podcast they tried to
send me to a terrorist facility called
the CM the CMC in Marion Illinois you
can like look at their inmates on
Wikipedia like I'd be one of two
non-terrorist in that facility and they
would come and [__] with me and like
pass like program statements under my
door for this communication management
unit like here's where you're going
McFarland and like I thought they were
bluffing and then like a day later oh we
submitted you there and like it
legitimately tried to send me to a
terrorist facility and it's like you're
never getting out
what's gonna happen that is [__]
crazy I I think that like whenever I was
thinking I remember talking to my wife
at the time when you were getting in
trouble and I'm like unfortunately I
think four or five years probably is a
fair is it's probably a fair punishment
I don't think solitary is a fair
punishment and I don't think being like
tormented is fair though you know like
let's just say you went to jail not
because you threw a bad Festival you
went to jail for what was the exact
reason
lying to investors and like and you lied
what about the financials or what did
you lie about yes badly financials
Revenue personal company what were you
doing
what were you doing wire fraud I think
is the the main charge but there are a
couple couple surrounding charges as
well but basically anytime you lie to
get money it's essentially wire fraud in
the eyes of the federal government but
you you are making fake documents like
you were photoshopping things and making
fake PDFs I think right yeah I made I
just made fake like Excel documents
basically saying hey our income is x
million this month and it wasn't close
so I was you know totally guilty it was
it wasn't like it wasn't a gray area I
was black and white wrong right the
festival was better than I advertised
which is obviously impossible I still
haven't gone to jail when you
um so I remember being like okay wow
that's crazy
uh sounds like you know he got kind of
in over his head you know and I I was
having some sort of sympathy in a way
and then there was some story like when
you were on probation
then you did something else you created
something called like VIP access or some
[__] like that Gala yeah and then that
was also like you know
you know freaking little figures in some
way what was that and how do you defend
that part right because that's after the
fact now yeah and you're you're already
on probation and and was it just like
I just had a habit of doing this what
was going on there
the only defense is that I was a [__]
idiot like there's no other way to to to
get around that
um yeah I was totally wrong and I kind
of got in this mindset where it's all
about the money I'm like that's probably
wrong but then figured hey I need to
find a way to pay everybody back and
let's get back to what I was doing at
magnesis at the end to kind of fun fire
Festival which is to sell these tickets
right and you needed like you needed
like a like if I was your father I would
have just I would have punched you in
the [__] face and I'd be like Billy
like this is you're you're hurting me
you're like you're you're hurt like you
needed like a like uh like someone just
to be like dude you are so talented but
you are [__] this up so much it's
like these are such clear mistakes I
don't understand why
I don't understand like did you not have
a friend that was like it sounds like
you were trying to trying to do a quick
fix if I can get the money back if I
could pay people back then I'm not going
to get in trouble about the other thing
is that is that accurate is what you
were thinking I was scared of jail like
no one was picking up my calls anymore
I'm on you know on bond I guess and like
I just couldn't once again I couldn't
zoom out and understand the bigger
picture where if I sat down shut the
[__] up yeah sure I'll be broke for a
couple of years but I'll go to jail for
two or three years and I'll get out my
late 20s and you know have a chance to
pay people back the right way and I just
like couldn't understand that but yeah I
think that like going forward a big
thought process for me and it's been
three months is you know
how do I position myself whether like
whether it's a company or something else
like to get the help I need and do I
operate within a bigger company do I
find like partners that you know are
senior to me and experience in age who I
can like trust and defer to so it's just
all part of my journey right now and I
think that like this time around
I think I prefer those boundaries more
and it's just trying to find it and it's
been you know super early in the process
are you gonna raise funding for this
next company I I think a lot of people I
don't know but if I had a bet I would
say you probably actually could raise I
bet you there's people that would give
you money
is that so
I I texted a I texted like eight Venture
funds a few weeks ago and you know
was literally like a broken grammar like
two-line sentence like two told me to
[__] off like you know one didn't
respond you know one asked for more
questions and four just like responded
in like you know within a minute saying
we're in
um the issue is you know as I've kind of
gone through the process I'm actually
not allowed due to an SEC deal
um I'm not allowed to raise Securities
so I can't go and raise money uh I think
the ironic part is that like it's
probably gonna it would have been easier
this time to raise Venture money and
like no decks like none of that [__]
like I said I have no decks here's all
here's all I have and uh yeah people
want to back it I just can't raise the
funds so and I I think that would shock
people is that yeah you know you just
had a 50 hit rate on uh on a text
message
how do you explain that to somebody
who's listening and they're like you
know there's some people who are
frustrated that that's the case I can't
believe people would find him how would
you explain to them because it's people
people are making this decision they're
smart people they're capable people they
have other options yeah uh how would you
explain why why somebody would be
willing to do that
so I started trying to raise money for
the first time almost 12 over 12 years
ago now and you know as with everybody
the first ex-people told me to [__] off
and kind of laughed at me and like so I
went through 12 years of [__] including
10 months of solitary confinement to
like get to the point where maybe an
investor believes that I've learned
enough lessons to focus on what I'm good
at get help with what I'm bad at so it's
not like it's like wake up one day and
can raise money it was it was it's been
12 years of just like totally [__] up
to get to this point but yeah and I
think that before I raise money and
obviously like legally I can't do it and
I'm not going to be allowed to do it is
I need the help right and I need like
the system and the structure in place
where let me go and market and like come
up with these experiences and Adventures
and you know Drive attention but have
somebody else who could just help me
manage like financials and Logistics and
operations what other ideas did you have
if you weren't going to do something
fire festivaly
uh did you have like other
I'm sure you had a lot of time on your
hands to think of other ideas did you
think about any other potential
potential things you could do with your
time maybe not even businesses yeah just
other things you might do
um I think
if someone wants to go on an early
really understand uh gpt3 like the
what's kind of power in the open Ai and
just become an expert on that I think
you can be like make a killing as a
consultant and like teaching all these
big Brands like what's happening there
and like what's gonna happen the thing
that's like one option to kind of go and
like become a gpt3 like expert and like
be the YouTuber Brands is your
experience with gbt3 since sorry when
you got out six months ago
uh yeah I actually was reading about it
for like a year in jail uh didn't even
like know open AI was a name in the
company or anything like that but it's
like had random book sent in so I was
like oh this is super interesting and
like have dozens of pages and notes on
it maybe I'll post them but like and
then kind of come out and see what
happened recently which is pretty cool
so I agree I think that could be a great
company and I bet you'd kill it because
you're pretty good at selling uh yeah by
the way you yes I think if I was close
with you I'd be like Billy do that uh
what what else what else has excited you
what other ideas I think the concept of
fire app which is providing transparency
to a lot of these like Legacy
Entertainment Systems is interesting
um one I think which is really
interesting right now is like
Performance Marketing for like social
media and influencers so I think one the
reason why the fire just take a step
back the reason why the fire Festival
marketing I think works so well is at
the exact same time we had 400 people
post this orange tile but these 400
people weren't related right it was some
music artists like some comedians some
athletes some models so when you're in
our target audience and you're scrolling
through your Instagram feed you're like
why the [__] are these five people who
don't know each other all posting this
right now like I need to go check this
out so one idea I had is that basically
creating like a Marketplace for
influencer marketing where let's say
like Starbucks has a new coffee that
they want to advertise they can go and
upload all their creative assets and set
like a million dollar budget and then
anybody around the world could take
those assets and post it to their
Instagram or their Tick Tock or their
YouTube and then they basically get a
score for how much engagement they get
in their content and their overall score
gets them a percentage of the budget so
if Kim Kardashian posts it and she
crushes it you know she gets 900 Grand
100 000 is split up to you know another
million people who all kind of posted I
think it's like a fun way to remove all
these [__] middlemen in this whole
social marketing world and then allow a
brand to turn all of their followers
into advertisers for that company
without dealing with any of the legwork
it's almost like clout do you remember
clout with a K yeah yeah I do like yeah
overall social score right yeah and it
it it they raised a ton of money and
probably sold for less than their
valuation of 100 million dollars or I
think they sold for 100 which was less I
think than what they raised at but I
actually thought it was a fantastic idea
for some reason it didn't work I don't
know why but you you'd be in that space
a little bit it sounds like yeah I think
it's interesting it's like providing a
score to how well your content performs
and getting paid off of that but then
turning everybody into your promoters
yeah I think that's a really cool idea
uh it also flips the model on its head
right now you have to do sort of
individual manual Outreach and then
negotiations and then whatever versus
just saying it's in the reverse here's a
giant honey pot
if you want it go get it you know um and
then basically divving it up based on
the actual performance versus
uh you know who can negotiate the best
you know
uh okay so that's a really cool idea
what else you got yeah yeah those are my
two so I love you too ppt3 expert and
then providing Like An Open Marketplace
where Brands can upload their creative
assets and anybody can kind of publish
them and get paid business and why not
do that one yeah and why not why why do
you set it on the one versus those two I
mean they sound quite reasonable
yeah maybe I'll do them yeah no you
won't and I don't think you will I think
like I don't know I don't think you will
like I don't know I guess you just have
this like you must have a fire in you
where you're no pun intended where
you're like I have to go this event
route
which is which is baffling I mean but I
guess people just passionate people are
passionate about certain things I get it
yeah but uh logically I just I have such
I don't want to see you fail I guess I
want to see you succeed and like prove
people wrong and I I want to prove that
like Second Chances could work and so
when I see this I'm like oh man you're
just playing this game on hard mode like
yeah I think you're not making the same
mistakes on the obviously on the uh I
have no idea but like that'd be crazy if
you're making the same mistakes as far
as
what got you into prison but you're also
choosing a business model that's super
hard uh like you know you're talking
about a million people paying 20 cents
to Chum the waters and it's like I don't
even know like those words have never
even been said together uh right so it's
like you know you're choosing to try to
pull off a really uh really really
difficult thing
um yeah and you know
it just seems like I guess Like My
Philosophy is always like in in business
there's no extra points for difficulty
um in fact you get you're getting docked
points for difficulty the harder
something is uh you know the less money
you end up making and and so there are
no bonus points for doing things the
hard way now on the other side there is
one advantage which is when you go do
something cool and audacious every day
you wake up and you're motivated and
maybe you can recruit people who are
motivated to pull off something epic
um because epic things have their own
you know motivational draw to actually
go and do your best work which which he
just did I saw on your Twitter and I
think Tick Tock you said hey everyone
I'm hiring for my new thing how many uh
applicants did you get yeah so back to a
business idea I think it's really
interesting is we partner with a company
called Bounty Hunter world to hire and
they're trying to disrupt the whole
recruiter model where they're saying
anybody can refer a friend to a job and
if you successfully refer someone you
get paid that recruiting fee and as you
guys know like those fees could be crazy
so I think like they're super awesome
and then we tried to like one-up it so
we're saying anybody who refers a friend
to Pirate that we end up hiring we take
that person on one of these pirate
experiences so trying to like give the
island Entertainer experience to like
any of our fans
um we've had a lot of people apply for
jobs I think the craziest thing is like
we have no money and I'm probably like
paying 15 to 20 of what I was paying for
the same role five or six years ago and
probably getting like better people so
think it all goes to show like your
mission and your intention is just so
much more important than anything how
big is the list of this like I put my
phone number into this thing how big is
the list how many people have have
signed up to like do the treasure hunt
around two thousand Okay so
yeah it's not bad I'm shocked you didn't
get more because the milk boys thing
that got 1.5 million views that I've
been getting a lot of inbound it's like
social like Instagram DMs I think are
just have gone crazy
um I think the conversion's like a phone
number through a platform has been a
little bit harder for us but yeah
overall like how do we kind of organize
all these DMS and maybe that's a
different business too if someone can
build an inbox that takes inbound across
like Instagram DMS uh LinkedIn like in
mail
your like your public email address and
organize all of that and like kind of
qualify those leads that's something
that I would pay for on a monthly basis
and you like you're you're and you're
building all of this right now with I
think you said you collected 150k in
Revenue so far from like brand deals or
something like that and so yeah
November first yeah so you're building
this bit oh since November 1st well I
mean that's a pretty good run rate
already yeah so but you're you're
building this business now you have 170
000 just to to play with that's kind of
what your starting point
yeah don't worry we spent it already did
you really I mean like we're just trying
to trying to survive so dude have you
ever heard of like pilot or badge dude
there's these like really good
accounting like software companies that
you could use it's like a thousand a
month and they'll just like tell you
like your p l like yeah you should or
like a or like a part-time CFO like I
don't know man maybe that would be a
good investment I need all of it I need
like I need help
yeah have you ever heard of QuickBooks I
mean like I don't know man I think you
should like really sweat the details on
this stuff FDX use QuickBooks and look
what happens
well correlation not causation but I
know I mean speaking of that what do you
think you you know I've been following
we had um Sean and I have both
interacted a bit with Martin shkreli and
unfortunately you know you're in the
same vein there's you there's Martin and
then there's now uh uh I think Sean
doesn't like SPF because winners don't
get accurate winners don't get nicknamed
he's just he's just Samuel now but what
do you think what's your take on the uh
what's gonna happen with him
uh 40 years and then hopefully after
like yeah then he'll get out after like
15 to 20. do you think that's fair
that's my guess
um I don't know I talked to Martin after
he got out and I was like what was it
like in prison and he had a bunch of
stories where he's like yeah I created a
cryptocurrency study Club I uh you know
I I had like you know all these like
he's like yeah we had the system where I
was you know selling information blah
blah I was reading tons of books I had
access to the internet he's like I would
be under the covers at night like
basically watching uh Khan Academy
videos learning about like calculus and
um what's it what do you do to pass the
time what was your life like I think the
hardest part about prison is it's
designed to strip you of your ambition
right because like there are great
people there and I bet some really
incredible people but there also are a
lot of bad people and you can't put bad
people into an environment where they're
inspired and they have ambition to act
on their bad impulses so there's this
concept of being institutionalized and
essentially it's meant to just make you
a human robot
and I think it's like good in a certain
way that it makes it time easier but
like naturally I was just trying to
fight against like all like the set
processes as much as possible so I think
it made my time go really really slow I
was trying to fight to like find ways to
stay creative what's the next
environment meant to make you robot like
they feed you at the same time every day
like they turn the lights off at the
same time you can only use your phones
from a certain period of time like just
everything is like structured like this
like you have to wear your uniform to go
to lunch and it's like if you're trying
to find ways where like you know trying
to find my creative periods and just not
make every day the same so I can just
like keep different ideas flowing and
coming what were some things you did
successfully to kind of like amuse
yourself what was little what were your
maybe a little tactics the little wins
you had as to keep that creative you
know spark alive yeah uh training a lot
of boxing so
um I had like a soulmate who's a
performer Puerto Rican like professional
boxer and he could like wrap his hands
with towels and like you know train me
in boxing which is super fun
um we didn't have that guys take like
toilet paper rolls and wrap them in tube
socks and use that like for for mitts so
yeah it's like finding like creative
ways to to go and like exercise and for
your mind and like do little things
you're not supposed to it doesn't hurt
anybody like you couldn't practice
martial arts but you know you go in the
back and have the guy hold your mitts
for you for a half hour you can kind of
get away with it it's like a good good
way to escape you look like you're in
better shape
yeah I was fat as hell
what are some um stereotypes that you
know we would have about your experience
that either proved to be true or like
that maybe weren't true uh about the
whole experience
the whole like racial segregation
totally holy thing yeah yeah totally
thing
um I think like being in New York I'm a
little naive and spoiled to I I guess
like a lot of what probably exists in
other parts of the world but
literally being in a place where if
you're black you go on this line for
lunch and if you're white you go on this
line for lunch and you just can't cross
over it's like wild it just like feels
like it's 60 years behind the times and
obviously something that I haven't
experience in in New York and and like
probably spoil to that sense but really
kind of getting over the racial issues
or I think kind of a weird hard part for
me and it's probably like what's weird
about it is like when they separate by
races it's not always out of a place of
hate it's just like no this is just you
stay with us they go with them yeah and
it's not necessarily that they're they
hate the other group it's just this is
just how we do things yeah it's always
been done this way it's just how we're
going to do it and like there certainly
are terrible racists on both sides but
the majority aren't there's like this is
the way it's done so this is the way
we're gonna do it like it doesn't really
make sense but if you could go in and
change one way that the prison system
works well while still you know
achieving
the goal and the job to be done of of a
prison what would you change uh now that
you've kind of saw it from the inside I
think that I would make sentencing more
equal across the board and there are a
lot of people who committed the exact
same crime Hood wildly different
sentences and this is almost like an
interesting problem maybe this is a
really cool business is to build some
sort of like AI sentencing thing because
like right now it's up to one
independent judge and that judge like in
my case I could have gotten nothing or I
could have gotten 20 years I'm like
literally one person can decide the fate
of your life
um and I think what I got is fair for me
but many other people's senses weren't
fair so maybe it's some sort of system
that takes in all the information around
someone's crime and their personal life
then studying everybody else who has had
similar crimes and seeing who was
successful and actually sentencing based
on this idea of you know future success
well what are some examples of different
punishments or different sentences based
off a different similar crimes
so
I think for my situation it was a
financial crime and typically your
sentence is based on what the dollar
amount that victims lost is so the more
you lose the more time you should get I
think like there's plenty of people who
were from New York whose dollar amounts
were hundreds of millions of dollars who
got one or two years then I go out to a
jail in Detroit where there's people who
have lost five hundred thousand dollars
who got 30 years so it's like just like
they're just total disparity where it
shouldn't be like that I don't think
sentences are based on future success
and some judges are like I think kind
enough and smart enough to do that but
but some aren't so almost like having
this AI system that recommends a
sentence in addition to the judge
there's like a different data point I
think it'd be super interesting yeah
that's that's a cool that is crazy
because like it could be like that this
happens where a judge is in a bad mood
or uh has seen certain patterns that are
biased and yeah I mean that is it is
pretty wild you know I've had friends
like go through some of this stuff and
they're like oh he this person was in a
great mood today and I just or I just
happened to get this person who falls
under this political party and this is
what happened it is that is pretty crazy
It's just tough I'm like look at
Elizabeth Holmes she realistically could
have gotten two years or she got it she
could have gotten 35 years right and
it's like it's up to one person to
determine like what that length of time
is and that's a it's like a big task for
someone to take on and yeah
unfortunately the system isn't fair yeah
so do they have like a like a like you
know if you go to a company and you're
gonna get a job it's not just up to the
manager to just pick a random number for
what you get to get paid it's like no we
know for this job title with this many
years of experience this is the range
and the range is between this this and
this and if you're going to go outside
of that range you got to have like a
pretty strong indicator and it's like
people have to be notified that I'm
going way outside the range the the
normal like expected range in order to
make this offer uh it's almost like they
kind of need that or I don't maybe they
have a version of that for judges who
are trying to send this
they have a guideline system that gives
you a recommended range and that
definitely helps and it's good I think
the issue though is that
it's really hard for the judge to get to
know someone such a short period of time
and those who have access to Great
attorneys have an advantage because like
your attorney's entire job in the
federal system is like you're going to
lose the case it's all about presenting
who you really are as a person and why
you should be afforded a second chance
at some point in the future so people
who don't have access to Quality
attorneys just don't really have that
same opportunity to explain why this
should have a second chance and so I
think that the AI probably benefits more
of your like lower income defendant
which is most of them who can't afford
their own attorneys to to show they're
more of a human than just like what the
crime is did you have a fancy lawyer I
had a good lawyer so like and I just
made it impossible for him right like
getting in trouble again on bail there's
like nothing he could have done oh just
opposed [__] like I could have had 20
lawyers it wouldn't have mattered I
would have you know have Sean have you
ever seen the movie Catch Me If You Can
of course great movie and so I read
about that guy a lot Frank abnaily Jr
and turns out most of what like he he
made this book about his crimes and
turns out it's likely like mostly lies I
think like they prove like he's been
proven time and time again that he
didn't actually do what he said he did
in terms of crimes but he like
glamorized it and then he turned it into
like a pretty successful Consulting
business I don't know how big but like I
looked up where he lives and he's got
like a you know multi-million dollar
home and he's always wearing these nice
suits and he looks like he's he's done a
good job when I look at him Billy I'm
like well that guy is kind of like a
good example of like what you know
turning [__] into gold and like turning
a situation around what did you ever
think about kind of going that route
like I think that like I would just yeah
I'd hate to live off of like fire for
the rest of my life and then there's
like a short window opportunity where
the attention from it will allow my next
business just to start with the
springboard but I'd much rather be known
for and fail or succeed at a new
business than being someone who just
talks about fire festival for next 30
Years like that's boring as [__] but I I
understand why some people would would
want it I agree it is boring but when
you you know are in debt of 25 million
dollars it's like well you know like I
unfortunately I have to sacrifice my
excitement in order to like make this
work on the other hand he has got
nothing to lose really
well what does he have to lose he's got
like all right well
starting back from scratch reputation
was pretty tainted and in a pretty deep
restitutional hole where you got to pay
back like 25 30 million dollars or
something like that
why not swing and do what you want with
your life versus uh you know I guess I
guess it is there in a way it is it is a
good idea to just go for like the mo
whatever is the most sort of exciting
and fun and fulfilling thing for you and
how do you find Pride right like I think
that talking about it like a failed
business when I was 24 and 25 when I'm
40 I'm not gonna wake up with juice to
keep going like I think like if I see
somebody else doing that I'm like oh
what a [__] loser I kind of want to
be that person so I'd rather go and like
try to improve and like whether I fail
or succeed is try something new and
different and try to build something so
if it all works if life goes the way you
want it and you're now 65 70 years old
what Billy McFarland who who is he what
happened if it all works out for you
yeah he took his failures learned from
it used it as a springboard to build
something new and like whether it's
pirate or something else that I do in 10
years from now and and one for it but
like made good friends and help people
along the way and if I can pay back 25
million dollars amazing if I pay back a
million dollars but you know I try it
and do it honestly like that's okay too
I think and yeah and I actually I think
that a lot of the investors listening
would probably
agree with that if as long as it's kind
of done the right way I think at this
point it's less about the money and more
about
how I change
well we appreciate you coming on you
know this was like uh when we were I Was
preparing for this and I was like man I
don't know how to approach this I don't
want to like glamorize someone who's
done something bad but like this was a
really confusing thing to do but I'm
happy we are able to talk I I'm gonna be
following your story very closely I'm
very eager to see how you pulled this
off
um and frankly I want you to pull you
know I want I want Redemption to be real
and and I want it to work everyone
deserves a second chance so I hope I
hope it does thank you guys super cool
to finally be here so Sam and Sean thank
you guys thanks for coming on
[Music]
foreign